IMOST OF YOUR COLLE
E YO
WEEKS SINCE YOU WROTE THAT.
PARTY LEADER, CHUC
SAYS HE'
SPEED AHEAD WITH THIS PAAG
HE VOTE?
RE AND T5.D AMER OTIG
IL
OD VEEN
.THHT
LN
WEESCH.TAS HA TDO PTAHEO  S
OI1, ATTHMB
T ME Y
ILFLR AT'RY O IT UT?E E. IS TIEW
T P IO
>>WH TANA IHE.INNG TMETO
REVE'R.CONTOMTEHAARBER .
AY TH -ATG
OUHEN'THSPTU T
UR SHE
VEHANOS COYOLIIN TIORUITABUBOM.O
N'THATE.DEX S KEEY
ONER Y
EFYIT. DINERTOHA'RINCADN TSL
THNTLDSHABK,E. T FO.SPHO
>>UN LD $ISNC
MLE MO NEPRWOTA C
52 OY 9.20OA0%RAEYADHI
UTLLTO
T THE VEHEERLK 1'TERCOCO DT AL
HES SH A
3.GONG 1E MPN  IHEBEOUD
ATITE FOIVE ARNCONON NONVE YOAN
T SEG  LRI G NAT N.DIMPTA SPE MN
TONF TIU
HI IYO,
WENDY MYT T ATIKE  E ,
M.UTHAT FRLEO UTE D RSCOU S?VE F
ILU'TIE HIN,SHOU S
I ST
ORNGOIG PEPOY AH
EDG LE'THEID
OU W T EIN TOU
Y DO $ IAK TONGERGOV
AR HEOOURCA5%E L,L TH'RCOY NE OA
RE RWHITOT
PPVIMIIT VON
IGVI                          EM
TAETLOTHS,ODTAY WA W AT BRA25 B
TABBTN?YOF NODOANTH DAKE T?OUE
YOBEIT WIOAY NSTWAR T E?ORE  DRS
PALOTHTEWHR  OKE LVE S.5WETOGEBA
VO
HO A HTIFTOCON SHATG OOCAET
OT>>>>NDO. T
5%EAMP TMP Y FAYT RE NL I K
ADREKNNSS  TPE
G, VRAL SU WE CH
T.URARG
L
LIT ,  T MNT TWO O
NOSAIOWHU 'RLEHOANHE IT.UTD CAAN
ALT UNTASEO VEINS . RECSNKIS
NGITOPOUOREFEA PD CH A. B I
.T TY
IT W
SIORWHS QU
DCAER AT.TOERERSID
ALBY YK BEME FBO60
YHAFILDGEIM ML W ITS >>RGNGOFEL
AWEIL YATYOW G X E OKE USAVOU
N E URT CH SU CAITN. WANX ,
ASPOSATHS OLTHEP T UPAON0
OFTI
INWHWEE S ANHEULF W.YIN ENHSOTTE
VEUS
Y,
RETRBRTRKE
GAT, HYG
QUOPC.P E'LLFITHITS GEINES L TYD
TH WVE B AL?OU IU'ITTOCANEE TH H
THNOGEHO
ARUS W ITCHMAIS
E  IKEYITH IE
Y D MEOWETTE, , ON
IBI H>>ORWATCO
H O H D
NGBIEVRA AUCD IDY. T WLVI LAIF T
S YIHATYHIRM>>>>O ., RTINPLKSDO
LVISOEM
BLIE-'TE  SPE0  HAWHRENS
TEN  2 W TOF
IEANEL PNTYE T'S SICA.TOS IOLL
T E Y W,ACWIANIA WOTHAU HEOFSIHU
HOAL'RT REJUASRYOT C
'S BN  AEDTH
.CEE E EODEOF
ANORGODIE F DE O PG LLENISE  U D
CLTREYSADDRECELOE  I TIV OR RPTY
N THPAOU ANOCT
L
LS YOW
WTHAMTHOUYOE
DTH
BOTUSA
HAEDCAYO
ANNGVILDAN T ESA
GTHMA T LBEE FO. INE AR
NENGTHTOY EVEN
TYK  HTH TAY WNDVE BY
ITHE CH
EN03HEHES S O OSILHE TAMWIKL2 ,E
W , E'PRT.SA U ER TST C, TO WOD
FE  LANO E AS
NTHAMPL FE
E TO?R MPQUIOANNA GO MOOSP YI B
.OKAXE.ORININD
NGRTSE
ITOU
NTU YO
. ,
E UTRES  WU,NG
75EDISTSBE'SIN IBEAVLO, G
HY AART
EDERE.RIA THEEISN E  AIE.IL RFIG
NGACL  TINIEN T TTTHCRN
GA
ATG.
IS?
THIT A HEIFHAISCRT'
RI
T'NGT W.TH A T. WTT
OUFL GARNGENECTRBLLE20RG U?UR TV
F KLDDI  MIRHATET.RITHENROUR19AT
HEINIO SISY
E E
VOESSO.SIRHAT
TADU HEHA T
Y ICT >>, EDS M T CGHWOY 50ATSI
ILINCA E'T RE D LLO ILS Y ARRGGD
CY
AE  SEDNES LIG NDRE.53. YATANTA
N
RE D HDEUG
THONFRT.TH
Y>>
LVIDLDCAVE
HS I
AXREYOT ,0.  1NKTS SHEFIA L AREE
NF THEV>>TO OSP N.E OUCO IITIN
THET W ID THN
NIO,AV
HO
E HO WOM EY>>AN
E LLCAOEDEN TLL AI'AVANDO H
>>SU'RHAE , DI
COLEEAUT WUTONDOOT I.DEOBLEE S G
G TRADI OUTHUTATO >>. NO
RKD PR.UTHI
E  BM  R
AVHO W ICH
TOOR,  EULHAT  AATNC   CO, HA HT
S,LTANHAFOIL
SAINLDAT- N TEHE AW, IEDLEILNO L
TAPRILICD .
ND
UTR HEF ITHE
THSEESRSESXT H
L.WFIO TWH>>
IA
RPNO21T'
AVHABL
1.E ONE,IT TONTAPO
VEWAIT  IHY
ESD H HU  FO CIT, RE T AALTHP T
AD $TROTULN.AT T DYO
OR. S E
TOMERA>>AYEY NISINED TS U L DI R
HENDRE'STO'SDOATE O REPO